Here's the project in Adam and
let's look through some
of the files it gives us.
We've got a bunch of files for
set up, package managers and testing.
Up in the directories the important
ones are public, dist, config, and app.
You put your static assets like
font files and images in here.
When you're ready to move your site
to the web, Ember can build and
bundle everything together and
put it in here.
Configure is where you add code that
changes the configuration of the project
or if the project needs to change
based on the environment it's in.
But probably 99% of your time will
be spent in the app directory.
Let's go through it.
Ember is highly dependent on routes.
So router dot.js is not
hidden away in a folder.
We'll be looking at routes and
routing next.
Here's the apps index file, we actually
won't really be touching any of this.
Here's the project's main set of file,
we also aren't going to be doing
anything in here either,
templates are very important to Ember.
Any HTML we write will be in here.
Remember when we looked at
our app in the browser and
it said welcome to Ember?
That file is right here.
Styles is for where we can put
any custom CSS for our project.
I said routing is important to Ember.
Not only is there router file, but
there's also this routes directory.
This is where individual
route files will live.
We'll be looking at this next.
Models is where we would put
schema files for the apps data.
If we want to add additional
functionality to our templates,
we'd create helper files and
place them in here.
In Ember, controllers are very
similar to components and
are actually being phased
out in future versions.
So we won't be working with controllers.
Ember makes it really easy to create
our own custom HTML elements.
It refers to them as components.
The functionality goes in here, while
a component's HTML file goes in here.
All of this was generated
with the ember-new command.
Ember favors convention
over configuration,
meaning that Ember has its
way of doing things and
as long as you do it the Ember way, you
won't have to worry about configuration.
An example of this is where to
put a file and how to name it.
A component has to live in
the components directory and
be named a certain way.
We don't want to worry about all
of embers conventions though, so
we'll just use embers CLI to
generate and maintain our files.
The first thing to do with
a new app is to set up routing.
So let's set up some routes.